it has a big bulbous head beady black
eyes and eight squirming tentacles
it's the octopus many would call it ugly
and disgusting the one thing they
wouldn't call it is dinner but in Korea
octopus is considered a delicious treat
and there's one popular way of eating it
that doesn't require a recipe they don't
cook this eight-legged Beast they don't
even kill it they eat it alive
with eight arms and over a thousand
suckers the octopus is a mouthful
this meal won't go down without a fight
but sometimes it's not just difficult
it's deadly doctor that anybody know
what happened to me was I was trying to
eat it whole and a piece of tentacle got
stuck between my teeth and I choked on
it the vendor lived to tell the tale
but others haven't been so fortunate so
why would anyone eat a dish so slimy and
deadly it's simple Koreans believe
eating live octopus is a surefire way to
build strength and stamina that's why
some who practice the ancient martial
art of kendo loved to eat it kendo
demands concentration and endurance but
one of these students is at a
disadvantage American Engram Jones has
never experienced this boost from live
octopi tonight Ingram is determined to
prove his courage and swallow the deadly
meal
actually I was talk to America if it's
alive don't eat it I come to Korea and
it's alive and they eat it
Ingram watches carefully to learn the
technique this is how you do it this is
how you eat it this is the method they
wrapped the live octopus around the
chopsticks how I got back yeah he's
gonna eat the whole thing put it in
their mouths and hope their jaws are
stronger than its tentacles right now
it's Ingram's turn that's kind of big
[Music]
invites the grasping tentacles as their
powerful suckers sticks to his tongue
teeth and the inside of his mouth yeah
why not everyone know he's had enough
Ingram may be a great kendo fighter but
he's no match for the octopus chewing is
not the problem the problem is
swallowing it because it's so slimy and
it sticks to your tongue so it's hard to
swallow when he's sticking to your
tongue that's very difficult sorry guys
I tried Ingram is left with a new
appreciation for the courage of his
Korean friends they're brave they're
very brave I think they're very brave
and he's also gained a healthy respect
for the tenacity of the octopus